what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich for us
trying to get our lunch money right i'm
here with paulina she's in a prison
outfit it's awesome
sailor outfit no problem don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block five block buy's got three
products you can buy and sell crypto you
can deposit crypto and get a us dollar
loan
or you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest bearing
account
i earn interest are you i'm an investor
i sit on the board i'm a happy user
you'll be happy go get a blockfy account
go to blockfy.com
pomp go to blockfy.com just go there
right now and go to blockfly.com
pomp all right what's up all right so
your boy jerome powell
jerry stock picker jerry on a panel why
is he doing
panels anyway he's doing panels virtual
pin
virtual panel for the european central
bank forum
he said that the economy is completely
changed as we know it it's it's not
going to be the same
he said um kovid brought the economy to
a screeching halt and while it has
started its long road to recovery
it's never going to be the same we're
recovering but to a different economy he
said
um and it's going to accelerate existing
trends in the economy and society
including the increasing use of
technology telework and automation
we did not need jerome powell to tell us
these obvious things
yeah he's not wrong but do you know why
we're gonna go back to you know why
we're gonna go back to a different
economy
because we got fools in the government
yesterday the mayor of chicago she's
trying to cancel thanksgiving
that's what she's basically doing she
said hey you know what i'm going to put
out this advisory
you can't go into stores there has to be
less than 10 people
your family can't come over all this
nonsense
but she don't tell you that a week ago
she was in the street
with no mask on i'm getting a spam call
another [ __ ] spam call
the mayor of chicago was in the street
with no mask on
at the uh at the celebrations with her
white uh megaphone thing
going nuts so it's okay for her to do
whatever she wants
but it's not okay for you as a small
business owner to keep your business
open
or for you to go enjoy a holiday with
your family after a tough year
you can't do what you want to do but she
can do whatever she wants to do
it's foolish and my favorite tweet i saw
about this
why is everything it's like oh there's a
curfew 10 p.m
does covin stay away until 10 o'clock at
night coven only comes out at night
what is going on and the worst part
the worst part is that we are going to
go back to a different economy
but the problem is it's a
technology-enabled world
and a lot of small businesses that are
responsible for fifty percent of jobs in
america
are they're virtual they're at a
disadvantage they don't even have the
skill sets
to digitize themselves for me it's like
yes spend some time reading what the
news is saying about the macro economy
and what's going on
but also spend some time walking around
in your neighborhood and asking the
people who own these businesses how they
feel about it
we did that the other day talked to the
owner of a restaurant next door
and he he just looked so down he was
like pacing around
like he was literally depressed and so
we stopped he was like hey man what's
going on
and he was just so sad about the new
curfews in new york city and less than
10 people inside his restaurant all this
stuff that
yes if you're trying to curb a pandemic
sure but a lot of it is arbitrary not
backed by
anything and they're just doing it
because they can do it and so he's just
like
i don't know what to do at this point um
there have literally been curfews
announced
this is can't make this up there have
literally been things announced
you can't gather in a crowd except for a
political rally
or a political protest again doesn't
count foreign
until 10 o'clock at night kovit doesn't
come out uh for political events
it's nonsense either apply the rules to
everybody equally
or don't have the rules stop being dumb
the latest coronavirus vaccine
developments have brightened the outlook
for the u.s economy with ubs economists
boosting their gdp forecasts for the
country
so hold on a second so ubs had
originally estimated that the number of
coveted infections in the u.s
would approach zero by the end of 2021
but this week's vaccine news has made
the bank
bring that forecast forward by six
months
so end of 2020
i tweeted this this morning yeah this is
the beginning of 2012
no this is the problem what the hell
does the ubs economist know about
viruses
he's not an epidemiologist he's not a
virus expert
why are economists running models on
viruses
and why are the scientists talking about
the economic
impact of the virus it is like sending a
police officer
to a building that's on fire and then
turning around and saying
sending a fireman to a bank robbery what
is going on here
why are economists telling us when the
cases are going to be at zero
they don't know anything more than you
or i know
listen to the scientists read original
work
make decisions for yourself yeah we
don't have data you can't make good
decisions with bad data and the
economist
they got a hard enough problem they
can't even predict the economy let alone
the virus
well we have some data now paypal
removes
waitlist for new crypto service and
boosts
the weekly purchase limit to twenty
thousand dollars what do you think about
this
cool it looks like they had a lot of
demand
are you do you use paypal yes do you
yeah oh what about venmo yeah i use
venmo way more than paypal
i use paypal um so right now because
nobody's really like accepting cash and
cards like when i go somewhere and
there's a service i
can just use paypal whatever did i use
venmo for my haircut you they'd be
taking yeah
wow and plus i don't think they have to
like pay stuff on them
i don't i don't know what kind of
economy i'm promoting i think one time i
tried to use paypal when i was a kid
i was trying to buy something like from
china or something and
they were like paypal besides you guys
you know what's cool we can talk about
this in one second
but there's a really good profile this
week it's in bloomberg business week on
zell it's a us-based payment
uh company like venmo but it's exploding
in popularity in venezuela
and it's really really interesting
because obviously due to the
socialist government inflation has been
on a runaway train
and so there's been hyperinflation so
basically there might their currency is
worthless at the moment
the bolivar and they've been using zell
to pay for things and apparently it's
everywhere and um
venezuela is an interesting position and
a unique position because
there are sanctions on the country but
not on the people so basically they can
they can use a us-based service um the
problem is that
a lot of them are nervous if their
accounts get locked
because i mean they'll get in trouble by
the government of venezuela if they find
out they're using it it's just a whole
thing paypal
just broke open the damn oh okay we'll
go back to payphone
every no well zell is going to add
crypto at some point
paypal just forced everyone's hand 350
million users
on a quarterly basis or a monthly basis
i think
whoa they they have to you if you're in
financial services now you have to be
asking what's my bitcoin strategy what's
my crypto strategy
and like planet are just described right
with uh the venezuelans that are using
zell
you can either use dollars and be
potentially subjected to
seizures freezing of your account all
that kind of stuff you know confiscation
like all that kind of stuff
or you can use crypto and
figure out how to solve custody so you
have sovereignty of your funds
do we know what are people in venezuela
using crypto
bitcoin uh there are definitely people
using it i don't know how
uh proliferated it has become
if that's pervasive go ahead next
doordash file that's s1 filing
to go public uh it reports 149 million
in losses on revenue of 1.9 billion
through september
now let's remember doordash
has been one of the quote-unquote
winners of the pandemic
because it there was unforeseen demand
for its service
during cobit jordash is a food and
delivery company this is in my
anti-portfolio
this one hurts oh cause you okay you
could have invested but you did
when i was working at facebook in 2014
uh
a gentleman that i knew i was either 14
or 15.
uh that i worked with a colleague um who
uh is very successful
uh he had invested and he was telling me
about it and i even met with some of the
people on the team
um and uh i did not invest
um i did not do anything and now the
company's gonna be worth billions and
billions of dollars so
yeah happens sorry so um
when it goes public it'll join grubhub
and uber in the public market
doordash has the lead in u.s market
share among them with 49
of meal delivery sales in september
compared with uber's 22 percent in
grubhub
crub hubs 20 so i mean
the gorilla's coming it's pretty crazy
that they're the winner over uber i know
right
but that's what happens i like that
story good good for tony and the team
good for toe knee okay so
for four astronauts are slated to ride
into
orbit aboard a spacex crew dragon
capsule
this weekend kicking off what nasa hopes
will be years of spacex
conducting routine trips to keep the
international
international space station fully
staffed
spacex is getting up in there it's
just saying spacex launched the car into
space now it's launching people
i mean this has happened before now like
right last time when we did it actually
live uh spacex watch should we do
another one for
uh but remember we had trouble last time
i think we should just watch it on our
own people don't need to see our
reactions to people being lifted off
into space
my favorite part is that uh nasa is
sending three astronauts
and then japan is sending one
guess what the japan space agency is
called so we have nasa
nasa and japan is called jazza g-a-s-a
x-a jaxa oh jaxa whatever g-j-a-x-a
i wonder what the x stands for sorry
somebody let me know in the comments
all right what's next oh that's italian
man we're not gonna pitch it this is for
my personal purposes i opened a tab that
says
italian man 81 serenades um
his wife in the hospital from the street
because he couldn't visit her
okay we're not going to talk about this
this is my personal
you know views uh we got kind of a lot
of questions last time
or all right let's let's let's roll so
let's just see okay let's go
remember ask lm in the comments if you
use hashtag askgalenpluno we'll go find
them
brian brian
what are some books recommended for any
topic do you guys want us to tell you
to use your full name i just don't know
all right you go first okay
we'll go look for book go all right uh
the sun does shine
by anthony ray hinton it's a memoir
this man was held on death row in
alabama for 30 years for a crime he did
not commit
i'm going to say three books all
together just because they kind of go
together
rich dad poor dad the richest man in
babylon and think and grow rich
okay your turn educated by tara westover
a memoir by a woman who was raised by
mormon survivalist parents in uh
the hills of like idaho and she
never went to school and the first time
she set foot in a classroom
was in university when she went to
brigham young
and then she went and went to like
oxford and
harvard i think um she became super
educated but the whole idea
is kind of about what education what an
education really means
the dao of capital by mark spitznagel
what what's your next one
oh do i have one more yeah keep going
let's just see who runs out first
not gonna run out i'm not gonna run out
either
a house in the sky um
oh god what is her name the hard thing
about hard things by ben horowitz
um humans of new york by brian stanton
it's just called humans it's not called
humans well there's a few
the trillion dollar coach about bill
campbell
uh you can't look that's cheating no i
didn't i i was just stretching my neck
the uh elon musk by ashley vance
oh is it my turn yeah you ran out
no i didn't run out get out okay alex
from lgn
i don't know what that is but we're
gonna go with it what's the best quick
and accessible resource to help people
understand the perils of being
overexposed to usd
and underexposed to btc for people
asking me i always send them to my
bookmark
link bookmark to link of pumps what is
bitcoin and why it's important
masterwork
but if i'm trying to bring someone in
from the cold
i need something more digestible less
intimidating i shorter and more visuals
suggestions thanks yeah his face is not
very visual
okay go on i think the most
important thing that you can get across
i i don't have an answer in terms of
like a specific video or anything like
that but uh i do think that
um what you have to just explain is that
the dollar gets devalued and so
if you just um there's a video online
uh i think it is ray dalio has one it's
called how the economic engine works
it's on youtube i believe it's very very
good or how the economy works something
like that
and then bill ackman has one as well i
forget the name of
the video but it's something along the
same lines
and it's ackman basically standing there
uh as the thumbnail
he's like standing next like a stool um
that's another good one both of those
should help people understand kind of
how the economy works how money works
and also your monopoly example is a good
visual if you want to explain it that
way
yeah that's true you want to explain
your monopoly example
no it's more of a blockchain than
anything oh okay
elton asks how does anthony have such a
good memory i can't even remember where
i put my wallet
thanks you guys are awesome bang bang
how do you have such a good memory
he does have a good memory
what i don't know he would tell me that
in in
high school or school or whatever like
you know he would
literally memorize everything then the
teacher would try to catch him
oh yeah i didn't everyone knows i was a
horrible like horrible student
in school uh and i basically
if i ever if i ever hear something i
remember it and
uh not like um what are they called
photographic memory
i have the same thing yeah i don't have
that i have to hear it
but i have to also write it down in
order to remember it he just has to hear
it
yeah i just remember if i read something
if i hear whatever i do have pretty good
memory and teacher would be like
what do you think anthony and i would
just be just repeat
whatever the answer was and then i would
look at her and they would
teach would be like psycho engaged like
damn like didn't get him
and then you know what happens they do
that once or twice and then they never
ask you another question
like then you're good for the rest of
the semester i won't be coming over here
i'll be bringing that [ __ ] over here
i'll send your [ __ ]
do you have any tips on how to get a
better memory
mine is write it down with pen and pen
scientifically that it is proven that if
you hear something and you write it down
uh not type it but write it down uh it
is easier to remember
it's so weird i'm assuming typing is
less ideal than writing but typing can
help
but the other thing too is just like um
when i was a kid and i had to like study
for i think i like saved like two tests
ever in my life
um hence why i didn't know what they
were yeah well i think it was probably
like right after like my dad was like
i'm gonna beat your ass if you don't get
a good grade on this test
uh what i would do is the only way i
could study i literally could not study
any other way
then i would get uh flash cards and
basically i would uh it was like a game
like i would just memorize i could put
you know five hundred dollars isn't
exactly learning but yes
of course not i didn't learn anything
well you know i just like whatever but
it was just like i could memorize it and
then i'd get on the test and just like
and then just go hand it to the teacher
and they always thought i was cheating
and i was like no like i just memorized
everything
and then like a day later i don't
remember any of that but i did get a
c plus on the test okay i like this
question
leonard hey pimp and pump i love i like
that i'm pimp now
i've watched every episode since the
series began keep it up oh man leonard
i've barely watched every episode since
wondering what are the top three life
advice
like life lessons or advice you would
give yourself
you would give to your younger self i
butcher that question what are the top
three
pieces of advice you would give to your
younger self go ahead no you go first
okay one would be to have a little bit
more confidence
in what i can do i was always like oh my
god what if i mess up what if i would
ever
just be a little bit more confident um
trust that it's all gonna work out and
stop
worrying so damn much that's all that's
it
yeah those aren't very like exciting
ones those are like
well like i used to i was like a very
like i worried a lot i wasn't very
confident i was like
no i'm like what's up yo i'm on here
with no makeup
on i'm kidding
i'm kidding go on the three pieces of
advice i give my younger self
anything worth doing is worth overdoing
facts
facts okay uh the second one would be
something about bitcoin
invest in bitcoin no well just
definitely
uh to invest more right which kind of
goes back to anything worth doing is
worth overdoing
uh and then three is um
when i was younger i like i was
obsessive
about winning and like
that might that definition changed all
the time but it was just like
i had to go 100 miles an hour all the
time and
it didn't matter like i was just gonna
get there and
uh when you get older like you're just
like you know what like
i'm still going to win at whatever i do
i just don't need sleep eight hours
yeah i could sleep but you know i just
like chill out a little bit
um and so i think that there's something
to do around just like
yo you're gonna get where you want to
get like you don't got to freak out like
i
i just like be ready to roll like you
ever seen you ever seen the video of uh
uh p diddy puff daddy there's a video
sean combs
he's uh sitting at his desk old video on
the internet he's sitting at his desk
and uh and he's on a phone call and they
get him like right at the end of the
phone call and he's like yeah whatever
okay cool like we'll send the docs over
whatever
and he puts down the phone and he's hype
like some big deal or whatever
and he stands up and he like pushes a
bunch of [ __ ] on his desk and he goes
who's going to stop me who is going to
stop me what's next
what's next give me something new to do
and he's just freaking out
and he's young right but he's just like
he's so different
he feels like he's like uh invincible
right like he could just get anything
done that he puts his mind to
and when i was younger like that's what
i thought uh
as well but it was more of like i had to
put
a hundred percent of all of my time
energy focus everything into like
accomplishing that thing
now it's more of i can accomplish
anything i want but i don't have to have
that
like ruthless obsession with it
you still have you're still ruthlessly
obsessed with the things you do
you just have more balance but yeah i'm
just i'm just a little bit chiller about
i try to be a little bit chiller about
it you know every once in a while
sometimes he does get up like what's
next yeah
bitcoin is 16 500 bucks i told you i'm
i didn't say it kid show kid show but i
told y'all that [ __ ] was going to happen
all right what else anything else any
other questions that's
it i hope every single one of you has a
great weekend
i hope that they cancel christmas music
until after thanksgiving and how could
you
and if any of you follow me on twitter
you'll know
good morning to everyone except those
who call instead of text
see you on monday bang bang hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of lunch money
as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account there's
not very many places where you'll find
up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends